a new study suggests the johnson
johnson covid vaccine may not be as
effective fighting this highly
contagious delta variant
as tackling the original strain the
study comes from nyu's grossman school
of medicine
it says that more than 13 million people
who have received the single-shot
vaccine
may also now need a booster now we
should point out to you that this study
is based on experiments done in a lab
and not
from real world examples plus it has not
been peer reviewed and is not conclusive
johnson johnson responded saying the
company data shows a single dose of its
vaccine
had a strong persistent response against
the delta variant
this comes as the cdc says a delta
variant now accounts for 83 percent
of infections in this country cbs news
medical contributor there he is dr david
agus joins us this morning to discuss
hey dr david agus so if you've gotten
the j and j vaccine should you be
worried
hey gail no i mean it is a study that
should not have gotten media attention
it only looked at the
antibodies in the lab it didn't look at
t
cells which are the dominant way you
respond to vaccines so it's kind of a
meaningless
study that got a lot of headlines that
shouldn't have
well this is so frustrating then why is
it getting the headlines because there's
already
so many people who are freaked out to
begin with to get the vaccine in any
form
then you see a headline like this and it
just goes see i'm not getting it
it's very frustrating yeah no it's it's
frustrating and it's inappropriate i
talked to
the head of r d for j early this morning
and he was so
frustrated that scientists and doctors
are putting this out
in a non-peer-reviewed fashion that it's
like if you're going to drive from
new york to washington and you say the
weather means it's going to take me two
hours and 10 minutes
you forgot the traffic the bladder size
of the driver all of those things
matter and so it's really inappropriate
brother size of the driver i like that
but there it is what is troubling are
these breakthrough cases of people who
have gotten the vaccine
have there been more breakthrough cases
from people who had the j and j vaccine
or the pfizer vaccine or the modern
vaccine because it's troubling to think
i can still get it even though i've
gotten a vaccine
so you hit it the way you know a vaccine
works
is in the real world if there were more
breakthroughs with j and j
than pfizer moderna there's an issue
with the j j vaccine but we're not
seeing that right there are not more
serious cases or hospitalizations
with j and j or with pfizer moderna
they're all about the same and they're
very very rare rare serious ones and
they're very very rare hospitalizations
there are some that get some mild
symptoms after
exposure to the delta variant but
they're rather mild symptoms in almost
all cases
do you think there's a possibility david
that the people who've received the jnji
vaccine
might need a booster shot sooner than
others
i think everybody who received a vaccine
and who is
elderly or has issues with their immune
system at some point we'll need a
booster
i don't think it's j j specific you know
going into this
we knew that two shots were better than
one for an immune response so you make a
more potent immune response j
j is one shot they did a remarkable
thing and that there's a cohort of
people in the population
that only want one shot college kids
young individuals would never show up
for the second one
so there was a need for it and it was an
effective vaccine
that worked little bit lower immune
response than the others but it's worked
against every variant to date
doctor i guess just again real quick for
our audience just reiterate
if you've been vaccinated and you do
become infected with covet 19
what are the chances that you end up on
a ventilator or
possibly dying vlad it's near zero i
mean
literally near zero all of the current
vaccines work against the delta variant
and
every variant out there and that is why
every day i think
science and somebody up there for doing
this because we are safe at the present
time
all right dr david agus with words of
wisdom as always thank you doctor
appreciate it